So can we get an extra answer sheet in the exam center?
Yes, we can definitely get it. It is
your right. You
can definitely ask for an extra answer sheet for yourself. If
needed, the well answer reminded me that we are going to
do it. You heard it right.  We will
do paper solutions of all the subjects, like as soon as
our paper of 27th FB is over,
immediately after the English paper, you will
get its correct paper solution on the channel,
so there is
no need to provoke here and there, there is no need to listen to it from friends.
Similarly,
Science paper is on 4th March, ST is on 15th March,
Hindi is on 17th March and on 24th March
we will do Maths paper solution right
after your examination on your favorite channel
of Infinity with your favorite teacher.